hey everyone I'm Abbi sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen today's video has been
sponsored by ritual instead of reviewing
a traditional what ITIN add a video
today I'm going to be discussing a video
that's being heavily requested Elyse
Parker's carnivore diet 30-day challenge
now before we get into any of the gaping
dietary gaps one might run into in a
diet like this I want to speak to my
general healthy audience for a second
because a lot of you have asked me about
supplements I have always been super
clear that I'm a food first dietician
meaning that we should all aim to get as
much as we possibly can from a Whole
Foods and a balanced diet but for a lot
of us especially if there's some dietary
restrictions a well-planned supplement
regime can really help fill the
occasional gaps I recently discovered
ritual vitamins which is a vitamin
subscription service that delivers
supplements right to your door and it's
only about a dollar a day now I know
that the supplement world is really
overwhelming but I like ritual because
they have a really solid combination of
nine vitamins from vegan vitamin d3 to
Omega 3s all to support health and
they've got no colorants additives or
unlisted ingredients and if you find
that a multivitamin can sometimes make
you a little bit nauseous these ones
have a no nausea capsule design so you
don't have to take them with food so you
can check out the link in the
description to get 10% off your first
three months on ritual now if you want a
little recap because trust me a lot has
happened in a short amount of time
Elyse Parker used to have the channel
raw alignment where she shared raw vegan
diet tips and recipes however about a
year ago Elyse was one of the many
vegans to go on vegan and make a lot of
waves doing so I have a whole video
about going on vegan if you want to hear
my thoughts on the trend right here
anyway
this was obviously a controversial move
and since then hasn't gotten a lot of
love from the online vegan community
having said that Elyse has stated that
quitting raw veganism has helped her
feel a lot better and in August of 2019
she rebranded her channel as simply
Elyse Parker her diet after quitting her
raw vegan diet consisted of a balanced
diet rich in fruits and vegetables
grains dairy meat and alternatives in
December however Elyse took to YouTube
to talk about a diet challenge she was
giving herself to strictly follow
a carnivore diet for 30 days now you
guys all know I'm not a huge fan of this
in fact I did a whole video on the
carnivore diet in our friend goatee
right here but basically as it sounds
the carnivore diet is a really super
extreme version of the keto diet it's
literally just animal products no carbs
no grains no veggies no fruit nothing
else I'm just gonna put it out there
I've had a diet that's this restrictive
puts a woman at serious risk of
malnutrition
okay so let's meet Elise and find out
what her thoughts are on the carnivore
diet it has been shown to help relieve
symptoms from many illnesses such as
autoimmunity fatigue obesity
inflammatory diseases and more there are
a few theories on how eating only
animals who can be surprisingly helpful
for one's health
essentially the carnivore diet is a form
of an elimination diet which means that
it removes all common food sensitivities
from the picture there's also the factor
of cutting out all carbs meaning that
your body drops into ketosis which has
been linked to benefits like intense
mental clarity rapid weight loss and
better digestion
you may be wondering but what about the
body's nutritional needs won't you lack
some of the necessary vitamins and
minerals that a more balanced diet can
provide well actually most of the
advocates for the carnivore diet claim
that meat contains all of the vitamins
and minerals that your body needs to not
only survive but to thrive so ELISA
speaking to some of the alleged benefits
of the carnivore diet like relieving
fatigue obesity inflammatory disorders
she also talks about how the carnivore
diet puts you in ketosis and is a form
of an elimination diet because it
removes all common food sensitivity um
interesting perspective okay so the
proponents of the carnivore diet often
describe this as a type of elimination
diet and in my experience as a dietician
I can tell you that a safe and
beneficial elimination diet should look
nothing like this now traditionally an
elimination diet is used to identify
food sensitivities and develop an
individualized nutrition plan to help
reduce or even eliminate symptoms
usually it involves eliminating a small
component of the diet like gluten or
lactose or FODMAPs and then introducing
elements back in in various proportions
so that you can gauge the response you
would never eliminate a bunch of major
food groups in their entirety as the
carnivore diet would suggest you
definitely wouldn't aim to eliminate
them for good
in fact the traditional focus of an
elimination diet is often on the
reintroduction of these foods so that a
professional can carefully isolate the
unique problematic food with this
carnivore diet many are proposing that
the elimination of all foods except for
animal products will make you feel great
and you won't need to reintroduce those
other foods that's not an elimination
diet that's potentially malnutrition now
Elise also talks about how meat
supposedly contains all the vitamins and
minerals that your body's need to not
only survive but to thrive
I want to flag this point because this
is not necessarily true yes you can get
a variety of vitamins and minerals from
meat however there is one that is
particularly important that you might be
missing out on in significant amounts
and that is vitamin C now if you
remember from your high school science
class sailors used to get scurvy aka
vitamin C deficiency because their died
was mostly made up of fish and meat they
were eating any fruit or veg vitamin C
is a powerful antioxidant required for
growth and tissue repair it's an
essential vitamin because our body can't
make it so it has to come from our food
or supplements you may find small
amounts of vitamin C in raw liver and
eggs
however it's not typically found in
cooked animal foods water soluble
vitamins like vitamin C are susceptible
to being lost during cooking like
leaching out into the cooking water so
to prevent a huge loss of vitamins when
cooking vegetables you'd want to roast
or broil them instead of boiling and
let's not forget about fiber meat
doesn't give us any fiber and that's a
shame because fiber can do a lot for our
health not only has fiber being linked
to improving cardiovascular health by
lowering
blood pressure and cholesterol fiber
also promotes a diverse gut microbiome
which improves our immune system
digestion satiety and regularity now I
know at least we'll go on to say that
her digestion has been unaffected but it
can take a long time for the gut
microbiome to completely change so I
would expect things wouldn't be moving
so well down the line now many
proponents of a carnivore diet will cite
cultures that have historically eaten
just meat and we're not deficient in any
vitamins and minerals like the Inuit for
example however you won't find certain
meats eaten by the Inuit like whale fat
for example in your standard butcher box
or a local butchery they've also been
able to avoid vitamin deficiencies like
scurvy because they typically consume
whale skin which is rich in collagen and
vitamin C and these specialty meats may
be particularly hard to find depending
on where you live let's see what else
she has to say I experienced the more I
can relate to people in all facets of
life and coming from a history of being
vegan for almost 5 years I know very
well what it's like to lose myself in
the identity of a diet culture and to
lose true open-mindedness after a very
humbling experience of losing my health
my current intention is to really
understand rather than judge and what
better way to really understand other
than diving straight into an experience
that challenges me to get the heck out
side of my comfort zone and to release
any pre-existing beliefs
I completely admire Elyse for talking
openly about her dietary journey and
falling victim to dye culture I know
that it hasn't been easy for her and I
do agree with her that it's important to
get out of your current mindset and open
your mind to new ideas beyond your
current philosophy that being said I
don't agree that any of these 30-day
extreme diet challenges will help you
challenged I culture at all this stunt
is simply transitioning from one extreme
to the next and while I know Elise isn't
planning on sticking to this carnivore
diet forever
I don't believe that diet should ever be
approached with so much haste and
restriction a diet instead should be
completely tailored to you based on what
you're craving
and what your body needs not
sensationalized antics to make a point
and when I say diet I do mean it in the
original sense of the word like the
kinds of food that a person habitually
eats it's not intended for weight loss
it's intended to be something that
shouldn't feel like it's a challenge to
uphold
now while toxic die culture of course
exists in the plant-based world it also
exists in the carnivore world I mean
even though I thought I would like to
forget I think we can all remember this
guy but heck dye culture is alive and
well no matter what your dietary
convictions changing your dietary
patterns unfortunately doesn't excuse
you from this so let's see a little bit
more about what Lisa's eating fish eggs
but I needed to get me through at least
the first week of this challenge
ensuring that it was all grass-fed
pasture raised and organic I also wanted
to set very clear guidelines for myself
on what food and drinks are allowed and
not allowed so I decided to let myself
keep to comfort throughout this
challenge for the next 30 days
bulletproof coffee and matcha because
hey I'm human and honestly having a warm
caffeinated drink to look forward to
every single morning helps make this
challenge so much easier to navigate so
it's nice to see that Elyse has the
option to purchase grass-fed pasture
raised organic beef but I can see this
diet seriously
racking up the bills very quickly also
on the coffee I mean I'm totally in
agreement with her on this I would never
be able to give up coffee or my special
kind of drink for 30 days so I'm kind of
happy to see that at least isn't being
so hard on herself to have to forego
that as well I don't know I haven't
really had like absolutely amazing
digestion so far and I want to make some
changes to see if maybe we can enhance
that so yeah I think grazing throughout
the day which basically means like
snacking having smaller things like I'll
have some eggs I'll have some bacon I'll
have like a little bit of steak I'll
have some smoked salmon but I haven't
been having like set meals and I'm gonna
change that I'm gonna start having two
meals a day
so the first meal will be like a few
hours after I wake up I'll have
bulletproof coffee right when I wake up
and
wait a few hours how my first meal and
not really snack in between meals that
way my digests digestive system gets
like more of a break and we're gonna see
what that does because in the past
whenever I do that my digestion is
really good especially eating mostly
meats okay so that was a little shaky
but let's talk about it
so basically Elise talks about how in
the first few days that her digestion
hasn't been the best and it's likely
because she's gone from eating a diet
rich in fruits and vegetables and fiber
to only eating dairy products and meat
now studies have shown that a diet low
in fiber like the carnivore diet of
course could increase your risk of
constipation at the same time proponents
of the carnivore diet often cite this
one 2012 study that found that reducing
fiber intake actually reduced
constipation and improved digestion
however these results were only found in
people who are suffering from chronic
constipation so it's unclear whether a
healthy individual following a low fiber
diet would experience those same effects
especially because it goes against every
other dietary recommendation we ever
give about digestion meanwhile several
other studies have found that fiber
helps improve regularity by increasing
fecal bulk and increasing stool
frequency hence the recommendation of
getting 25 to 38 grams of fiber per day
as for the claim that intermittent
fasting or having two meals instead of
lots of mini meals improve digestion
there are a few studies that have found
that intermittent fasting may help with
IBS symptoms I mean one study did find
that fasting groups had significant
improvements with seven out of the eight
IBS symptoms compared to the regular
diet groups who reported improvements in
three out of the eight IBS symptoms but
this is a small study and is the only
IBS fasting study that I could honestly
find since IBS symptoms are response to
eating some anecdotal evidence found
that it may be helpful in managing
symptoms for some people but aside from
anecdotal evidence there are any really
good real studies exploring the role of
intermittent fasting on digestion in
healthy individual
so instead of grazing throughout the day
Elise may benefit from more structured
meals but also you know snacks in
between so that she could feel fuller
without the need to graze of course
eating two meals a day may work for some
people but in general eating every three
to four hours can help you feel
satisfied until you can get to that next
meal and also help with maintaining you
know equal and consistent blood sugar
levels when I first transitioned from
the vegan diet back to eating meat I
made a point to learn about the
importance of meats quality and how much
of an impact it can make both on our
health and the environment
at this point I believe that most people
are aware of factory farming but for
those who are unfamiliar factory farming
is an industrial system of farming mass
quantities of livestock in a very
confined and often unsanitary factory
it's definitely in your best interest to
source 100% grass-fed and grass-finished
beef I've teamed up with butcher box to
shed some light on how to source high
quality meat and opt out of factory
farming entirely ok so Elise goes on
about the differences between factory
farmed meat and grass-fed meat and talks
about how she's a big supporter of
grass-fed meat and then also talks about
her partnership with butcher box now I
agree with at least here that it's
important to be aware not only of the
environmental impact of eating meat but
also an animal's welfare now while the
research is still unclear on the safety
of an all meat diet one thing that I
think is quite apparent especially from
what I'm hearing here is that a
carnivore diet is really freakin
expensive yes you may not be spending
money on other foods just meat but if
you also want to eat your meat that is
ethically sourced and comes from local
farmers and is grass fed know that this
costs a premium and for most people is
just not doable we did the math for you
and were shocked to find out how much
butcher box may cost if you're following
a carnivore diet so in a day most people
would have to eat around 3 pounds of
meat to meet the average 2000 calories
in a day that means you'll need to eat
21 pounds of meat per week
and 84 pounds of meat per month so
butcher box offers a monthly big box
size that contains 16 to 22 pounds of
meat and the price is two hundred and
thirty-eight dollars but the monthly
size will only last you a week so to
meet your 84 pounds of meat per month
needs you'll have to buy four boxes
which will cost you 952 dollars per
month that is definitely not cheap and I
am popping in Fred update to share with
you that ever since I forget what day it
was but ever since I decided to start
like more so intermittent fasting and
having two meals a day instead of just
grazing and like eating whatever my
digestion has been on point like legit
[Music]
another update for you is like even
though my digestion is amazing and I
feel like super like mentally clear
right now I am a little bit missing the
freedom of being able to eat anything
that I want like I don't know most days
I'm fine with it but some days
especially in social settings I think I
mentioned earlier like on day one or
something that that was gonna be the
hardest part for me and it definitely is
whenever I'm out and about I just wanna
just get whatever I want to get normally
like it's gonna be mostly animal-based
anyway but being able to get like a bun
for a burger and not just have like a
burger patty would be amazing so I'm
really glad that Lisa is mentioning that
she misses her food freedom and finds it
difficult to navigate her diet and
social settings this is a really common
concern with really any kind of
restrictive diet because food is
inherently so social and well we now
have a lot more plant-based options in
restaurants you would have to put
together a really unique set of requests
to try to eat carnivore
while out not that you would likely go
out very often considering the markup on
restaurant steaks is legitimately insane
okay so let's finish off by hearing
about Elise's conclusions of her 30-day
challenge the main physical changes I
noticed were definitely
fat loss and increased power in the gym
I did end up losing around two pounds in
the full 30 days and my physique changed
slightly but nothing too crazy I mostly
just felt more lean and more comfortable
in my body so that was definitely a plus
for me and the main mental change I
experienced was having way more stable
energy and focus throughout the day like
literally every day and before starting
this challenge I was eating a pretty
balanced diet including meat and plan
some things like gluten-free bread and
dark chocolate and I remember feeling my
energy fluctuate during that time and I
would like randomly crash after meals
especially if they were carb heavy and
that didn't happen to me at all in the
past 30 days so when I first started I
was really wanting any form of carbs
that I could get my hands on but after
those first few days passed it was
pretty easy for me overall sure eating
this way was definitely challenging at
times and I remember that there were
definitely some days I was getting bored
of eating meat but I never felt like
insanely restricted to the point of
discomfort and whenever I did have the
desire to eat something that wasn't
carnivore the feeling passed pretty
quickly and something I did to make it
easier on myself was just expanding the
variety by including things like sashimi
oysters and crab so I wasn't eating just
steak and eggs every day and I know
you're all probably wondering what the
heck happened to my digestion from just
eating carnivore for 30 days straight
and this may sound surprising but my
digestion was honestly totally fine in
fact it was way better than when I was
vegan
also the more beef jerky and dehydrated
meat that I ate the slower my digestion
- but that that one's kind of a
no-brainer and most mornings I would
wake up with a flat and empty stomach
which wasn't as common on my diet before
I drove into this challenge ok so Elise
goes over some of her kind of concluding
thoughts she talks about how she lost
fat and increased power in the gym she
lost two pounds in a month she felt more
lean and comfortable in her body
had better concentration her cravings
went away her digestion in Peru
and she woke up with a flat stomach
which all these youtubers seem to aspire
to
okay so let's unpack some of these
outcomes first of all let's talk about
the weight loss on a carnivore diet as
with any restrictive diet since you're
only eating meat you'll likely take in
less calories over time and eventually
lose weight like Elise mentions she had
cravings for nutrient-rich foods like
veggies and carbs but she had to
suppress those cravings meanwhile she
had to like force feed herself eggs and
meat even on days she really didn't feel
up to it which usually results in just
consuming less food in the day also
protein fat are satiating macronutrients
meaning it typically makes you feel
fuller longer than carbs which may
provide a quick burst of energy no
surprise here but studies have found
that while a lot of people will lose a
few pounds on a new diet
soon after the vast majority of people
put that weight back on I don't
understand the point in losing a few
pounds in 30 days when you're just gonna
put that weight back on now let's talk
about the mental clarity on the
carnivore diet because of the role of a
ketogenic diet on managing the symptoms
of some neurological disorders and
epilepsy therapy many have claimed that
a high-protein low-carb diet provides
mental clarity and increased
concentration in a 2010 animal study the
ketogenic diet improved the cognitive
performance of aged rats
however motor performance remained
unchanged so while the early research is
promising and you'll find plenty of
people's testimonials of this there
doesn't seem to be enough high-quality
evidence or any long-term studies to
constantly assure us that the carnivore
diet would improve cognition next let's
talk about digestion on the carnivore
diet like we've discussed a carnivore
diet is missing fiber which can play an
important role in our digestion from
populating our gut with health-promoting
bacteria to improving regularity most
people will say that a high protein low
fiber diet would worsen someone's
digestion not improve it however some
research suggests that a keto diet may
improve digestive issues for people
suffering from inflamed
taury bowel disease or IBD so one study
found that people with IBS who are put
on the keto diet for 12 weeks
experienced a remission from their IBS
symptoms as well as changes in their gut
bacteria it's important to note that
these effects may be explained by the
fact that a carnivore diet or a keto
diet are just naturally low in FODMAPs
these are fermentable fibers in
carbohydrates that may trigger gas and
bloating and individuals with IBD and
IBS so fewer carbs in your diet means
less fermentable fiber which means less
gas and bloating unfortunately this
study doesn't give us any indication of
the effects of a zero carb diet in
general healthy individuals now while
Elise does mention that her digestion
improves as the days went on we still
don't know the effects of a carnivore
diet on the gut overtime so over time
eating fewer carbohydrates and
vegetables and only protein will
naturally change the composition of your
gut bacteria well Elise may be
experiencing fewer symptoms at the 30
day mark as the body adjusts to the new
diet in the long run I would be
concerned about the reduction in
bacterial species in the gut which could
lead to a whole host of other problems
that could be problematic because more
and more studies are realizing the
importance of our gut health and the
impact that it has on our health as a
whole from improving mental health to
preventing chronic disease we're really
just scratching the surface
understanding all of the roles that it
plays okay so why do I think that Elise
has decided to take her diet to the
extreme well there may be a few notable
things going on one is an effort to stay
relevant on YouTube now I don't want to
be a cynic but a few reasons why you
tubers or influencers take on new diets
and trends is not so much for health
reasons but to get views and stay
relevant online obviously a 30-day
carnivore diet video title is way more
sensational they're promoting a balanced
healthy diet just saying another
potential reason is her butcher box
partnership I like to believe that all
influencers aim to partner with brands
that currently fit their diet not build
a diet that fits another
and but this shift seems so extreme now
I have no qualms about sponsored content
I mean this video is sponsored but at
least disclose the partnership at the
start of the video to set the stage for
the content to come and maybe do this
first challenge video without a sponsor
first and if you like it and enjoy it
then work with meat based brands that
would just make a lot more sense to me
and third she seems to be really
disjointed in her relationship with her
body and food now I know that Elise
didn't go from a plant-based diet to a
full-on carnivore a diet but this
challenge is in itself really worrisome
ELISA said that in the past that a raw
vegan diet put too many restrictions on
her and her health was at risk she then
started to slowly introduce animal foods
into her diet and felt 300 times better
like with anything I think with your
diet balance really is key and I don't
see the fascination with some
influencers to go from one extreme to
the next
I know that eating a variety of foods in
moderation isn't a sensationalized video
title but for someone who's mentioned
that a balanced meal with plants and
animal products is working for her I
don't see the need to fix what isn't
broken it seems to me like she's so out
of touch with her body and food that she
can easily detach herself from her needs
and try whatever is trending I also
don't see the need to test out these
diets especially when the evidence to
support them is so limited next time if
a diet intrigues you do your research or
talk to a dietitian who can weigh the
pros and cons of these types of diets we
do our homework that being said if it's
currently working for her then great I'm
very interested to see what's next so
guys that is it for today
again I want to give a big thank you to
ritual for sponsoring this video and
don't forget about the 10% discount code
that is in the description below if you
liked it be sure to give it the thumbs
up leave me a comment below about who's
diet you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abbey's kitchen bye